I loved Philly and then we all did and  so we wish him all the best Kathie Lee  Gifford dishes on Billy Bush and who  could replace him in the 9:00 a.m. hour  on today if she had it her way that  person would be her pal Regis oh my gosh  nobody consults me about such things but  he's my first vote yeah but I'm not  gonna let him be on at nine o'clock  without me it's anyone's game but the  morning TV host admits it will be tough  to phil-billy seat at the desk  sweetheart shoes to fill I think he  seems such a pro people that do it best  for the ones that make it look easy  et caught up with Kathie Lee on the new  Carnival Vista cruise ship which makes  its maiden voyage in the US this week in  my 20 years with Carnival is their  spokesperson Ike was godmother for two  of the ships and so it's a real honor  it's a it's a tremendous honor I love  this company they were so good to me I  still work with them in various ways  they loved my wine and they serve it at  every meal so